en
[Musique]
c'est près de deux tiers des salariés
qui habitent à l'extérieur du territoire
et qui viennent rejoindre par la route
par également les transports en commun
nos différents sites et nos différentes
entreprises
on a encore de façon majoritaire des
salariés qui viennent sur leur lieu de
travail en voiture mais surtout de
l'agglomération à développer et à
renforcer tout son réseau de bus
nous avons la chance sur le territoire
d'avoir cette gare et de ces gars il
faut pouvoir rejoindre directement son
lieu de travail
et puis enfin et c'est une tendance très
forte que l'on voit depuis maintenant
plusieurs années c'est ce qu'on appelle
les mobilités douces donc en particulier
le vélo
[Musique]
oh
c' est aujourd'hui considéré comme le
deuxième critère d'implantation des
entreprises
après le coût de l'immobilier les
entreprises sont extrêmement attentive à
l'offre que nous déployons pour leurs
salariés en matière de transport et en
particulier en matière de transports en
commun
[Musique]
oh
de façon à pouvoir leur faciliter le
recrutement sur le territoire nous avons
mis en place un certain nombre d'outils
je pense notamment à la plate forme ce
qui emploie cette plate forme qu'on a
annoncé maintenant il ya quelques mois a
atteint plus de 10000 cv qui sont en
ligne